♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THANK HEAVEN IF IT
IS TIME NOW FOR FINAL EXAM, OUR
PROFESSIONALS AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER TO DETERMINE WHO HAS
BEEN PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION.
OUR DEFENDING CHAMPION IS
KATIE PAVLICH, SHE IS KILLED
OPPONENT AFTER OPPONENTS.
YOU BOTH KNOW THE RULES I'M
GOING TO REPEAT THEM FOR OUR
AUDIENCE.
HANDS ON THE BUZZERS.
I ASKED THE QUESTION THE FIRST
ONE WHO BUSES AND HAS TO ANSWER
IT.
YOU CAN ANSWER ONCE I
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU.
EACH ANSWER IS WORTH ONE POINT,
EACH INCORRECT ANSWER TO
TRACTATE POINT, BEST-OF-FIVE
WITNESS.
WINS.
A MAN IN NEW YORK CITY SET A
DANGEROUS WORLD RECORD FOR SPEED
SLICING A PIECE OF FRUIT, HE
CHAPTER THROUGH 26 OF THESE AND
JUST ONE MINUTE, WHAT KIND OF
FOOD WAS HE SLICING?
>> WATERMELONS.
>> Tucker: YOUR DECISIVE, I
THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
>> I THINK HE'S CUTTING
WATERMELONS.
>> Tucker: IS THAT MAURY
POVICH?
>> MY FIRST REACTION IS I'M
RELIEVED I DIDN'T KILL MYSELF IN
THE SECOND ONE IS I'M
EXHILARATED.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE AN ESOTERIC
YOU WEREN'T GUESSING.
THAT WASN'T MAURY POVICH.
THIS IS A MULTIPLE-CHOICE
QUESTION.
IF ONLINE SHOPPING HAS OF COURSE
CAUSED MANY BRICK-AND-MORTAR
STORES TO CLOSE.
AS OF THIS WEEK, WHICH POPULAR
BUSINESS FROM THE 80s AND
90s HAS EXACTLY ONE STORE LEFT
IN THE U.S.
IS IT TOWER RECORDS, BLOCKBUSTER
VIDEO, CIRCUIT CITY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO RISK LOSING
A POINT HERE, I DON'T KNOW.
>> BLOCKBUSTER.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE JUST
GUESSING.
WILL SHE BE REWARDED?
>> ALASKA'S FINAL BLOCKBUSTER
VIDEO WILL RENT OUT THEIR LAST
MOVIES AND CLOSE UP SHOP, IT
WILL LEAVE THE BLOCKBUSTER IN
BEND, OREGON, AS THE LAST
BLOCKBUSTER STANDING.
>> Tucker: FORTUNE FAVORS THE
BOLD KNOW WHEN YOU COULD HAVE
WOUND UP WITH THE NEGATIVE ONE
A BLOOMBERG INDEX THAT
CALCULATES THE NET WORTH OF
BILLIONAIRES.
HE IS WORTH 150 BILLION, HE IS
ALSO THE 25TH LARGEST LANDOWNER
IN THIS COUNTRY WHO IS IT?
JEFF BEZOS.
>> Tucker: IS IT INFECTED JEFF
BEZOS?
>> AMAZON SAYS JEFF BEZOS IS THE
RICHEST MAN IN HISTORY.
HIS NET WORTH TOPPED
150 BILLION.
>> I SUSPECT HE COULD LIVE ON
THE INTEREST ON THE INTEREST
FROM HIS $150 BILLION.
>> Tucker: GIVEN HOW HE PAYS
HIS EMPLOYEES YOU WOULD NEVER
KNOW HOW HE IS RICH.
GOOD ANSWER.
QUESTION FOUR, THIS IS YOUR
CHANCE.
THE RAIN CAME HOWARD IN
WASHINGTON ON TUESDAY AND
SOMETHING SPOOKY TOOK PLACE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE AT THE VERY
MOMENT TRUMP WAS SPEAKING TO
REPORTERS ABOUT HIS HELSINKI
TRIP, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THE LIGHTS WENT OUT.
>> Tucker: IS THAT TRUE?
TO THE TAPE.
>> INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, I HAVE
FULL FAITH AND OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
THERE IT GOES.
ARE YOU GUYS OKAY?
THAT'S OKAY.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER HELPING OF
DEEP STATE ANYONE?
SPEAK OF THE CAPITOL DOME GOT
STRUCK BY LIGHTNING.
>> THEY JUST PAID TO GET THAT
IF WE'RE MOVING TO THE FINAL
QUESTION HERE.
HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL RYAN SAYS HE
ATE HIS TRUCK, WHAT TYPE OF
ANIMAL ATE HIS TRUCK?
>> WOODCHUCKS.
>> Tucker: SERIOUSLY?
TO THE TAPE.
OF WOODCHUCKS LIVED IN THE
UNDERBODY OF MY SUBURBAN THEY
ATE ALL THE WIRING OUT OF IT.
MY CAR WAS EATEN BY ANIMALS.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> I LISTENED TO THAT BUT
GROWING UP WE TOOK THE CAR TO
THE DEALERSHIP AND THERE WAS A
SQUIRREL IN THE ENGINE.
>> Tucker: BUT NOT A WOOD
CHUCK.
>> SIMILAR SITUATION, I KNEW
THAT ANSWER.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE MORE
YOU GOT ONE OFF OF HER WHICH IS
BETTER THAN I WOULD'VE DONE.
>> THE ONLY REASON I HAVE THIS
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY OF THE ERIC WEMPLE SURPRISE
MONTHS YOU HAVE.